professor matpat oh it's too horrific to
look at oh you're right it's horrific to
behold who tattoos themselves using a
rune and a lotus i mean one is nordic
the other is hindu clearly they're
mixing their symbology don't you think
you're missing something ah well spotted
my boy i'd completely overlooked that
ankh which is egyptian ah the
misunderstanding of these cultural
symbols is
disgusting it's a severed hand oh huh so
it is which explains the two crossed
swords on the thumb symbolizing that
whoever our killer is he means violence
gee you think
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that uses tv shows to uncover
the hidden lore of real life today's
episode is sponsored by peacock in their
new streaming series dan brown's the
lost symbol which is the latest
adventure for renowned fictional puzzle
solver robert langdon if you're not
familiar well it probably should be
considering that he is the textbook
definition of a theorist his adventure
in 2003's the da vinci code was the
thing that made it cool to find hidden
clues in historic paintings and
ultimately expose ancient religious
conspiracies and if none of that is
ringing a bell for you well let me
rewind and start giving you some context
the da vinci code was a phenomenon it
was the second highest selling book the
year that it came out and it was
everywhere anytime you saw someone
reading a book nine times out of ten it
was a dan brown novel and if they
weren't reading a dan brown novel well
they were reading about a little orphan
wizard boy the da vinci code
single-handedly revitalized the
historical adventure genre suddenly
getting everyone looking for hidden
blades and chalices around their
everyday lives so as you would expect
the follow-up book in the series the
lost symbol became one of the most
anticipated books of all time selling a
million copies in a single day which is
why it's exciting to see it finally get
made into a series that's out now to
catch you up our protagonist is robert
langdon ivy league professor of
symbology not an actual department by
the way when a shadowy villain tries to
unlock an ancient portal lost to
time within the city an ancient portal
i need you to find it
then unlock it he blackmails robert into
solving a series of ancient puzzles that
only an expert in historical symbols can
piece together basically the whole show
is like an escape room on steroids where
your life is literally on the line it is
a fascinating premise for a thriller
that has robert confronting some of
history's most sinister symbols touching
everything from devil worship to
governmental conspiracies but the truth
is that each of these symbols has a very
real history and once you understand the
real-life lore behind these images it
becomes apparent that these sinister
symbols actually hold a very different
secret and once you know what that
secret is you'll never see the world
around you in the same way again
in dan brown's lost symbol one of the
first times that we actually see our
villain we learn that his body is
covered in tattoos and his forehead is
emblazoned with the eye of providence
now you're probably more familiar with
this thing as the all-seeing eye that
weirdo pyramid eye on the back of a
dollar bill and yeah you can immediately
understand why this thing would be
prompting conspiracy theories for years
a government using something literally
called the all-seeing eye as its
national seal that's the sort of thing
that conjures up images of big brother
surveillance states constantly
monitoring you from its cyclopsian
triangle in the sky it also doesn't help
here that the latin is novus ordo
seclorum translated to new order of the
ages
that doesn't sound ominous at all but in
reality the new order was just meant to
signify that the united states of
america was beginning a new era having
just declared its independence from
great britain and from the latin on top
of the seal we know that there's more to
the story anyway koitis literally
translated as favored undertakings but
most widely understood to imply
providence has favored our undertakings
that's why this symbol has become widely
known as the eye of providence or
sometimes the all-seeing eye of god
stemming from the religious belief that
their successes were the result of god's
blessing it's not the government that
has its eye perched on top of a pyramid
looking down at everyone it's god who is
up above watching down and protecting us
this symbolism with the eye of
providence acting as the eye of god
watching over and favoring those below
can be seen in religious paintings
dating all the way back to the
renaissance with probably the most
famous example being the 1525 pantoremo
painting cena in a mouse where we see
the eye in a triangle reflecting the
christian belief in god as a holy
trinity or god in three persons and
radiating light to symbolize god's
divinity other famous religious
buildings use it too like the kazan
cathedral in saint petersburg or the
manheim jesuit church in germany of
course we've got to address the elephant
in the room though there's a common
belief that the presence of an
all-seeing eye on the back of the us
dollar and other u.s icons is indicative
of freemason influence in the founding
of the united states but if we look at
the actual chronology of the symbol's
history the evidence suggests that the
opposite is actually true by all
indications and records that we have
from the time the all-seeing eye didn't
appear as a piece of freemason
iconography until 1797 which is more
than 20 years after it first appeared as
a us icon in
1776. it's the freemasons who adopted
the symbol after it was already used by
the us so the eye of providence yeah
maybe not as sinister as it first seems
now creepy triangle eye is one of the
easier symbols to decode because its
uses are fairly recent after all the
united states is less than 250 years old
things get a lot trickier when you turn
to more universal symbols which is where
robert langdon's expertise as a
symbologist really comes into play take
for instance the circumpunct or circled
dot another icon the villain believes to
be the key to finding this sought after
ancient portal as such in the show it's
yet another ominous mysterious thing but
as far as symbols go it's pretty mundane
it's a symbol that's appeared across
many different cultures used time and
time again to represent the sun an
egyptian hieroglyphs it's a symbol of
the sun god ra in ancient china it was
used in chinese oracle script the
precursor to modern chinese symbols as a
symbol again for the sun sometimes
symbolizing a day and in the study of
alchemy it was used as the alchemical
symbol for the sun corresponding to gold
little did you suspect that as you are
doodling in your notebooks at school
that you're actually paying honor to raw
the whole time and while the parallels
to the sun might be its most common
usage it's not the only one for instance
it's yet another important symbol for
the freemasons
in 1868 manual detailing practices for
freemason members describe the symbol
like this quote the point represents an
individual brother the circle is the
boundary line beyond which he is never
to suffer his prejudices or passions to
betray him
wait so it's a symbol reminding members
of the freemasons to behave themselves
like don't indulge in your vices that is
not only not scary it's kind of lame
maybe our lost symbol villain didn't get
the memo because i definitely say that
murdering and kidnapping are the sorts
of things that this symbol is actively
warning against gotta read your
newsletters bud the fact that the
circumpunkt is such a simple and
universal symbol is a big part of why
there are so many different meanings
attached to it the more common and easy
to draw a symbol is the more likely it's
going to be independently created and
adopted by a culture for whatever
interpretation is most useful to them
that being said symbols don't have to be
that simple to become widely used take
for example the triskelion which the
villain in dan brown's the lost symbol
uses as his personal calling card often
leaving it near his victims throughout
the series it's actually one of the
first symbols that we see in the show
appearing etched on the floor of a
prison cell of course he didn't come up
with the design himself the use of the
triskelion or tri-scales symbol dates
all the way back to the bronze age it
can be found on pottery produced during
the greek period of antiquity and be
honest classic versions are even
creepier than the one in the show
because they feature three legs
circulating around a central point
examples of this can be found as far
back as 2000 bc and on money minted
around the 4th century bc interestingly
the symbol doesn't seem to have a
consistent or specific meaning
throughout history despite all that we
know about ancient greece this one is
left surprisingly unclear one
interpretation is that it's connected to
hecate the triple goddess considering it
often appears alongside other of her
symbols like three crescent moons three
ears of corn three grains of corn etc
over in sicily the appearance of the
triskelion symbol on currency was
probably due to the greek name for the
island trinocria meaning having three
headlands fun fact by the way a variant
of the symbol also appears on the modern
day flag of sicily probably the most
nightmare-inducing flag you could ask
for so we've just reviewed three symbols
often associated with sinister
connotations but in reality looking at
their real histories all three have
meanings that are perfectly mundane
surely one of these symbols from the
series has to be frightening right well
look no further than the leviathan cross
a double cross set over an infinity sign
this thing is everywhere on the show
robert finds it on an old alchemy table
it's pressed into the seal of a letter
in his mentor's safe the villain has a
tattoo of it on his arm in the real
world it's a symbol that was used by
anton levay the founder of the church of
satan which at face value seems about as
sinister as you can get considering that
they're a religious organization who
chose their founding symbol to be the
biblical figure described as the literal
prince of darkness look further back
though and you see it's just as mundane
as the rest the church of satan didn't
exist prior to 1966 and before anton
levay decided to appropriate this symbol
as a satanist cross it had a history
dating back hundreds of years that had
nothing to do with the satanist movement
back in its earliest usage the leviathan
cross was used in the study of alchemy
aka ye oldie chemistry back in the 16th
century they believed that there were
three prime elements those being salt
the material body mercury corresponding
to spirit or life and sulfur
representing soul and the principle of
combustibility the leviathan cross was
used to represent sulfur which is
probably why in the show robert langdon
first encounters it in a piece of old
alchemical equipment and that's it's
basically the equivalent of the big old
s representing sulfur on the periodic
table so then what happened well despite
it not having any satanic associations
the founder of the church of satan anton
levade took it and transformed it for
his use when he founded the church in
1966. some have speculated that the
association with sulfur connects it to
the fire and brimstone often associated
with hell in the underworld or you know
maybe you just thought it looked cool
and in a way i think that's actually one
of the most important and fascinating
themes of this show which is something
that we're told in the opening minutes
of the series when do benign symbols
become
malignant everything is about the
corruption of symbols robert goes on to
show his university a series of examples
of corrupted symbols the most famous
being the swastika what was historically
a symbol of good luck used by eastern
religions like hinduism buddhism and
jainism became corrupted by the nazi
party in fact in a bit of morbid
historical irony it was actually used
during world war one as a personal
symbol of a jewish german fighter pilot
named fritz beckhard who went on to find
himself in prison decades later during
the holocaust versions of the symbol
were also used by the finnish air force
and the latvian air force during the
same time period the point is that what
makes a symbol scary or evil isn't the
symbol itself but the associations that
become attached to the symbol and often
symbols are appropriated to mean the
exact opposite of what they originally
meant case in point consider the cross
of saint peter in christian tradition
this symbol is based on the martyr peter
the apostle the story goes that when
peter one of jesus's followers was
sentenced to be executed by crucifixion
he requested that he be executed upside
down seeing himself as being unworthy of
being executed in the same way as jesus
but what began as a symbol based on a
story about the humility of a devout
follower in more recent years has been
adopted by some groups as an
anti-christian symbol since the inverted
cross is seen by some as being the
opposite of the christian crucifix we
see this all over pop culture these days
with popular horror franchises just
picking up that ball and running with it
online this sort of thing happens all
the time robert langdon even mentions it
in one of the show's opening scenes what
was relevant then
is relevant now the difference is that
now people can push symbols out to
millions with the click of a button it
might seem a bit silly to compare modern
internet memes to ancient symbols found
in egyptian hieroglyphs or patterns
carved into ancient artifacts but robert
is absolutely right to make the
comparison internet memes are symbols
and like any other symbol their meaning
is defined by the culture around them
and the way that they're used among the
most infamous examples of these is pepe
the frog a character who originated in a
2005 webcomic you've probably seen this
character's face if you've ever been on
twitch where it's been featured in
emotes like feels bad man pepe hands
pepe laugh among others he was funny he
was sad but he was a benign webcomic and
then this once innocent cartoon frog
became popular with online hate groups
to the point that in 2016 the
anti-defamation league classified pepe
the frog as a hate symbol stating quote
while the majority of uses of pepe the
frog have been and continue to be
non-bigoted there is nonetheless a
subset of pepe memes centered on racist
anti-semitic and other bigoted themes it
actually led to the original comics
creator matt furry to launch a hashtag
save pepe campaign to fight back against
hate groups and reclaim the symbol which
became the subject of a 2020 documentary
titled feels good man while this might
seem like a new phenomenon it's really
just an accelerated version of an old
phenomenon that different groups always
try to claim symbols as their own and
thereby change their meaning the only
difference is that culture now evolves
at such an absurdly fast pace due to the
internet ancient symbols are really the
memes of the past but it's important to
remember that symbols ultimately have no
power of their own they only have
whatever meaning we as people choose to
associate with them and this is what we
see in dan brown's the lost symbol when
robert langdon finds a severed hand with
weird symbols tattooed onto each of his
fingers it's not the symbols that are
scary it's the fact that it's on a
severed hand left by the kind of person
who isn't above the idea of mutilating
and kidnapping victims likewise that
tri-stallion by itself isn't scary it's
the dead body next to it that you have
to be worried about symbols are at their
most powerful when you don't understand
them when you're scared of them when
they carry some sort of mysterious
meaning but by looking into their
history and understanding their origin
you defuse them of their power and
you're finally able to see them for what
they truly are probably some basic
doodles that you accidentally made in
your sketchbook back when you're in
elementary school but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and thank you once
again to peacock in their new series dan
brown's the lost symbol for sponsoring
this episode for more symbols and more
historical mysteries make sure you go
check out the show right now over on
peacock it is streaming as we speak you
are a connoisseur of good quality
entertainment i guarantee for you it is
good quality entertainment so go check
it out right now peacock streaming for
free